Join the discussion with nearly twenty five
thousand other David Pakman show viewers and
listeners on the David Pakman show Subrata.
You can find it at David Pakman dot com slash
r e d d i t. Some interesting posts I spotted
this morning. User King Vercingetorix. Oh,
boy. I've posted a link to an article about
Donald Trump retweeting a conspiracy theory
which claims that, Joe, that Osama bin Laden
is still alive. And this actually did not
get a lot of attention. But this is an example
of the hyper normalization that we are seeing
during this presidency when the president
of the United States read tweets and signal
boost something as outrageous as the conspiracy
theories purporting to claim. And I say purporting
to claim because are they really claiming
this in a serious way? I don't know. But purporting
to claim that Osama bin Laden, for example,
was never really killed, that should be major
news. And in many other countries, it would
be grounds for, you know, a vote to a no confidence
vote for the leader. But it barely even made
news here in the United States. Really bizarre
stuff. Also from the sub at one of our viewers,
this is one of the most upvoted posts in history
on the David Pakman show sub Reddit, one of
our viewers who goes by the name. Okay. Interview
posted a picture of herself with a mask with
a David Pakman show t shirt, now a collector's
item and a an I voted sticker, voting early
and reminding everybody to be safe out there.
A beautiful post, much loved, much loved by
the David Pakman show Reddit Community. Let
us know if you've been voting early, how it's
been going. I got a few emails and different
pictures from people at different polling
places. A lot of people voting early. And
then lastly, User F.D. Kaplan is making a
request of me, a vocabulary request saying
let's avoid using the word interregnum and
use interim instead. And that is a linguistic
etymological request. F.D. Kaplan says that
interregnum quite literally means between
kings and that it feels inappropriate to use
what is typically a metaphorical reference
to kings. When Donald Trump is maybe not going
to accept the results of the election in a
pseudo effort to declare himself king, so
I will use it. The interim period, or what
I hope is the lame duck period, that's really
the term I want to be using. Maybe interregnum
wasn't the right word. Join the discussion
as more than 24000, nearly 25000 of you already
have on the sub. Read it at David Pakman dot
com slash r e d d i t.